what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome to film review Friday but before
we get too far into this I do want to
say that I apologize if the video
conditions are a little less than what
you'd like my webcam kind of struggles a
little bit when it comes to lighting
that's anything other than daylight so
it's a little darker than I would like
but what can you say I need to upgrade
my webcam and this in these videos and
these film review Friday videos these
are not going to be a weekly thing
simply because comic book films are not
coming out every Friday this is going to
be an instance where we review Marvel
comic films that have come out the
morning of the midnight chilling so
after the midnight showing on Thursday
night going into Friday morning I'll do
a upload a video that Friday discussing
the film and in this one we're gonna be
talking about Captain America the Winter
Soldier so this video is gonna have some
spoilers in it so I would suggest it if
you guys have not seen the movie yet and
you don't want to have anything spoil
for you I would say to go ahead and turn
the video off now and maybe come back
and watch it at a later date otherwise
keep watching so I felt like Captain
America the Winter Soldier
was a was an absolutely amazing film it
was it was great it was it's probably to
this date the best Marvel film that I've
seen and the reason why I think is
because it combines a great balance of a
reasonable story some drama and some
action with a lot of the Marvel films
that we've seen today it really kind of
feels like watching a Michael Bay film
although not as bad as Michael Bay films
Michael Bay's films you know things just
explode for no reason and no one really
knows why of course we have some context
with regards to what takes place in the
previous Marvel films but this one seems
to be a little darker it really seems to
be a little more gritty and we kind of
get into some pretty unsavory things
especially when we go to the scenes
where Bucky Barnes his mind as being
wiped you know it was really kind of I
wouldn't say shocking it was really kind
of it's something that you really didn't
expect to see to hear guys screaming out
in agony like that while his memory is
being erased it was it was really kind
of an intense moment you know for
seconds we are introduced to some cool
characters to some characters that in
truth I didn't really expect to see in
this movie or at the very least aren't
really important enough to be honest to
be mentioned in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe at this point were introduced
to Falcon Sam Wilson and Falcon is a is
a big time ally of Captain America but I
don't really feel like Falcon is a
necessity
I mean Falcons kind of you know the
Marvel Cinematic Universe universes
version of Archangel simply because the
Marvel Studios does not actually own the
rights to the x-men which includes the
character Warren Worthington the third
or Archangel I kind of felt like you
know Falcon was forced into the movie he
didn't really seem necessary and in
truth he didn't really contribute much
to the film with the exception of the
fact that he was just something cool to
watch it was a little disappointing just
because I feel like if they had intended
to include him in the movie they should
have given his character a little bit
more as opposed to effectively being the
sidekick of Captain America you know I
thought that he could have been a little
more interesting than that but again you
know in my personal opinion I don't
really think he should have been in the
film in the first place now what I
thought was really kind of interesting
with this movie is were introduced to
Sharon Carter agent 13 who is the niece
of Peggy Carter although we don't really
go into anything with her character
she's introduced as the neighbor of
Steve Rogers and he's actually unaware
that she's been tasked with the
assignment of guarding Steve Rogers to
make sure that nothing happens to him
but we don't really see any development
of her character but what we do see is
Steve Rogers pairing up with Black Widow
Natasha Romanoff now this is really kind
of interesting to me because Natasha
Romanov are in the Talia Romanoff
depending on what you want to call her
Black Widow and Sharon Carter actually
appeared around the same time in Marvel
Comics within you know 10 years of each
other or so I believe that Sharon Carter
appears in tales of suspense issue
number 77 I think and I think that
Natasha Romanoff appears in tales of
suspense issue number 54 so they're
really really close you know even then
just in terms of the issue numbers but
what we see is Black Widow really kind
of undertaking the role and acting
almost the exact same way that Sharon
Carter did in the Marvel comic depiction
of Bucky Barnes return to the comic book
universe and this is what I thought was
kind of intriguing to me because a beg
the question what does Marvel Marvel
Studios gonna do when it comes to the
character of Sharon Carter you know
because we've already had the character
established of Black Widow we already
know who she is and if Sharon Carter is
going to become the love interest of
Captain America and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in the same way that she does
in the Marvel comics then if she want to
be depicted the same way she is in
Marvel Comics and if she is then people
are gonna look at her and see her as a
duplicate or a copy or a cheap knockoff
of Black Widow and this is what's really
kind of interesting to me I'm curious to
see where Marvel Studios is gonna go
they may very well just follow the same
pattern that we've seen so far and we'll
see Sharon Carter taking up pretty much
the same kind of role that Black Widow
does but she'll have more of a personal
involvement in it because she is the
direct love interest of Captain America
and so she really has more at stake when
he gets into assignments and when she
follows along with him because she
doesn't want to see him harmed you know
it was interesting to see some of the
characters that came back for example
Zola from the first Captain America
actually came back as a computer
algorithm which I thought was a pretty
cool concept and in Marvel Comics or in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
reason why is because we actually see
dr. Zola later on in Marvel Comics but I
think that he's part of a cyborg and
he's actually got like this big this big
TV screen so to speak in there and his
face is depicted in that so it was
really kind of a tip of the hat to Zola
lost a picture in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I'm sorry in the Marvel Comics
we also see a guy named Baron von
Strucker and Baron von Strucker is
actually in the mid credit scene when we
see Quicksilver and the Scarlet Witch
and we'll get into them here in a second
because I was a really really fun part
of the movie
Baron von Strucker is one of the top
ranking members of Hydra and he is
actually a really really cool character
in terms of his involvement but he
really is kind of like a throwback to
the archetypical
German villain that is to say that he
has a monocle and he speaks with a
German accent you know and he's you know
just kind of what you'd expect if you
met a German bad guy you know it really
kind of falls perfectly in line
that but the reveal of him in the
post-credits scene means that Hydra is
still going alive and well and they are
just as strong as they ever were however
were so I'm really kind of excited to
see how this takes place in addition we
had no conclusion with regards to what
happened with the Red Skull after the
events of Captain America the First
Avenger so we don't really know what's
gonna happen with the Red Skull we don't
know what's gonna happen with him we
don't know what's gonna take place we
don't know if he's gonna come back and
so for us it's really kind of
interesting to see that Hydra is still
alive because it may be that the Red
Skull will return and reestablish
himself as the foremost authority and
the organization of Hydra now
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch were
really kind of cool here because we only
got a glimpse though we only got you
know maybe a few seconds or so 10 or 15
seconds just enough for us to see them
and to know that they are going to be in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but here's
the cool thing there's really kind of
some illusion that we can draw here in
terms of how it is that Quicksilver and
the Scarlet Witch are going to be
included in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because as you guys know in our
previous discussion about the Scarlet
Witch we learned that Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver are of course twins her
brothers and sisters or brother and
sister Pietro Maximoff and Wanda
Maximoff and they are mutants but
because the Marvel Cinematic Universe
does not own the rights to the term
mutant or the x-men there had to be a
different way to include them in there
and so I think that what Marvel Studios
is going to do is they are going to be
sort of you know the kind of an addition
to the project that was done in order to
bring the Winter Soldier into the scene
and so what we learned of the course of
the film basically is that Bucky Barnes
his body was recovered much the same way
as it was in the Marvel Comics and that
he was subjected to the Super Soldier
program but he wasn't given any super
powers who was just given you know the
fighting capabilities of Captain America
and in a cybernetic arm that gives him
enhanced strength and so on and so forth
but I feel like with the Scarlet Witch
in Quicksilver what the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is going to do is they're going
to say that the Winter Soldier was just
one part of this program and that the
other parts of this program are composed
of other individuals who include the
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver and I feel
like that's how they're going to tie the
man
that the that Hydra the organization
Hydra was experimenting with giving
people superpowers and that the Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver were the results
of that how well this will go over I'm
not entirely sure to be honest it really
this kind of depends on how they depict
them I will say that people are very
very picky especially comic book fans
when it comes to how individuals are
depicted when you transfer them from
comic books into films and so again you
know no one really knows how this is
going to happen we may most likely just
kind of have to wait until the Avengers
comes out and you know maybe we'll get
some backstory from them in the age of
Ultron maybe they'll get their own
personal movies in which we'll get the
actual full backstory of how was they
gaining their abilities it's really kind
of up for debate at this point now to me
the coolest part of the whole film the
biggest part of the whole film was
something that was it was something that
was mentioned nothing really mentioned
it was just something that was shown and
unless you knew what you were looking
for and unless you were familiar with
the history of Captain America the
moment would be lost on you there is a
scene where Captain America and Bucky
Barnes are fighting and Captain America
throws his shield at Bucky Barnes or
something like that and Bucky Barnes
holds the shield up for a split second
and to me that was a big deal because I
have a feeling that's a tip of the hat
and a homage to the fact that if some
future point in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Captain America is going to be
assassinated the same way he is after
the civil Civil War storyline and Bucky
Barnes is going to pick up the role of
Captain America now whether or not this
is true I don't know but the fact that
Chris Evans had recently stated that he
didn't really want to act anymore
and he had negotiated his contract with
the Marvel films Marvel Studios from
nine movies down to six movies seems
like a pretty strong indicator that we
will see him killed off and Bucky Barnes
will take up the role it is also
entirely possible that we may see him
killed off before the Avengers the
Winter Soldier I'm sorry the Avengers
age of Ultron and that he will actually
return in the Avengers age of Ultron we
don't really know yet I mean we don't
know how in-depth the guardians of the
galaxy is going to be in terms of its
involvement with earthbound characters
and the Avengers if it has any
involvement at all but I do think that
this is really kind of a big deal
because I think that at some point along
the line we will see Captain America
now one of the big reveals I think a lot
of people were really kind of curious
about this one of the big reveals and
Captain America the Winter Soldier was
Stephen strange and this I think was
lost on a huge number of people because
when I was in the theater and I was
watching the movie there's a scene where
they're talking with one of the guys
from Hydra and they're talking about the
weapons system that Hydra is
implementing using the technology that
shield has seeing is how they've managed
to circumvent and in to infiltrate
shield they talk about how one of the
purposes of this weapon system is to
eliminate people who are threat to Hydra
and one of the names that is mentioned
is Stephen strange now this was a very
very big thing because watching the
watching the video or watching the scene
in the movie a lot of people were just
as excited as I was people were like yes
Stephen strange and a lot of people were
just like who's Stephen strange
didn't know who he was they're like who
in the heck is Stephen strange Stephen
strange or Stephen Vincent strange is
dr. strange he is a super popular
character in Marvel Comics and it's
actually really really awesome that he's
getting his own film he is the sorcerer
supreme the foremost authority for the
most part with regards to magics and
wizardry in the world of Marvel Comics
and he can do so many things he is such
a powerful character that it's really
kind of irritated people in Marvel
Comics because Marvel will use him as
kind of a scapegoat you know when all
else fails and the Avengers are back
into a corner and they just can't get
out of where they at where they're at
suddenly Doctor Strange appears and the
problem solved so it's really really
exciting to see him brought into the
into the silver screen and of course
we'll do a video about Doctor Strange in
the future but overall I felt like
Captain America the Winter Soldier was a
great film it was a really enjoyable
experience I would suggest you see in
theaters because it really seems to be
one of those movies that you need to see
in theaters I saw it in 3d I won't
really go as far as to say that it's a
necessity to see in 3d you don't really
need to see it in 3d and in fact I would
probably hold off on it just because of
the cost of 3d it cost me $15 to see in
3d that's just for the movie tickets
it's really not worth it at that point
$15 just kind of out
just to see a movie in 3d I would say
just go see it in 2d you're really not
gonna be missing anything it's really
not gonna make that much of a difference
in terms of what you're seeing but you
know it's it was it was an enjoyable
film I will also say that despite the
fact that you may have some reservations
about it do not be discouraged by seeing
Robert Redford in this film because
Robert Redford is one of the best actors
in Hollywood and in truth his role is
Alexander Pierce in this movie was very
very similar I felt to his role of
whatever his name was in the movie spy
game I don't know if you guys ever saw
spy game that was an amazing movie with
Robert Redford and Brad Pitt and it's
one of my top five favorite films to
this day which actually might watch this
after this review but um it was very
very reminiscent of that he seemed very
very similar to the same character in
spy game I felt like he was a great
addition to the movie and in fact his
role his acting of the character
Alexander Pierce really seemed to be so
natural that you would really believe
that he was the character Alexander
Pierce that was really kind of how I
felt he was in this movie it was it was
a really great experience so um so yeah
I would highly suggest checking the
movie out definitely see it in theaters
of course it won't kill you to wait and
watch it on blu-ray but I thought this
is one of those movies that you really
need to see on the silver screen so with
that being said I hope you guys enjoyed
this review if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace but in
the backstory of Ultron what we learn is
that Ultron is the result of creation at
the hands of Hank Pym and Hank Pym had
been kind of delving into the idea of
artificial intelligence and Ultron was
the first step along that process